now back to the breaking news we were
telling you about it's affecting
Travelers this morning all around the
country flights are being delayed
Nationwide today due to a computer issue
it seems that the FAA that's according
to the agency for more on this that's
bringing Chris Van Cleef Chris good
morning to you what do we know so far
well Gail this is the notice to air
missions it's basically a safety alert
system that gives airline pilots last
minute updates about where they're going
the the situation between the the
airport they're leaving in the
destination they're going to things that
are sort of developing uh in the moments
leading up to the flight it's a safety
critical system that is not working
properly and that has forced the vast
majority of flights scheduled to depart
this morning to have to hold I spoke
with one of the major airlines they
indicate they're able to dispatch some
aircraft manually but that's a very
intensive process planes that are in the
air are able to continue operating so if
somebody is on an overnight flight that
flight is going to continue coming into
its destination you know flights that
left Los Angeles last night for
Washington or New York for example that
are approaching their airports if you're
heading to an airport this morning
prepare for delays and disruptions the
FAA says they are working to get the
system back up but that it's not fully
operational at this time and because
it's safety critical that's going to
determine whether or not flights can
resume in any sort of meaningful way is
getting that system back up and running
we do have a statement from the FAA here
where they are basically acknowledging
that there is an issue that they are
working to get the system fully restored
this notice to air mission system there
does appear as the FAA says some
functionality here they've said earlier
that they were working on repopulating
their system so with any luck it will
come back quickly but you know the
morning really sets the tone for
Airlines and so when you delay the first
two batches of flights in the morning
people may feel this throughout the day
today
all right thank you very much Chris your
phrase safety critical sticks with me we
want to make sure they get this right
thank you so much we'll talk to you
later on